chris look
i for all the struggles of the patriots
i look and i see number one patriots
nine and one and i just feel like no
matter what gets thrown at them no
matter where they are no matter what
they do no matter who they play they're
just gonna keep winning games and they
need to hold that one game lead over the
ravens because if they finish with the
same record the ravens take the one seed
in the afc well yes i i mean i'm with
you that's the the common thought i mean
new england's just gonna continue to
find ways to win you know despite their
offense not being as strong as we've
seen in their past now this week the
cowboys come into town and then they got
the texans and the chiefs you know
they'll be tough i mean they will be you
know i don't think i don't think we can
look at new england this year and just
think they're gonna blow anybody out you
know not with that offense so all those
teams yeah they got to deal with the
patriots defense but i think a lot of
those teams are going to look at them
and go yeah but we we think we can hold
you know brady in new england under 20
points too now 20 points might not be
you know 20 points might be the
benchmark for all new england needs to
do on a weekly basis they got a big
challenge this week a team that can pose
some of the same problems that the
baltimore ravens did to them
overpower them up front you know all
their linebacker sets and things like
that dallas can kind of say great put a
lot of linebackers on the field we got
this offensive line we're going to smash
it down your throat and then you know if
you want to play one on one outside with
gallop and amari cooper and randall cobb
they like their chances there too now
new england special on d there's no
doubt about it but i think them and the
ravens are clearly the two best teams
after that i mean it's a toss-up to
where you want to go and where this ends
up is three through six it could go a
lot of different ways right now because
i could see a lot of these teams you
know losing a few games down the stretch
yeah back to the patriots too you look
at their schedule they've got the
cowboys and they have at the texans
chiefs come to town
at the bengals that is obviously a win
yeah stunning if there's anything other
than a blow out there and then the bills
and the dolphins to end the season
really the next three games are the
toughest and buffalo won't be easy but
the next three are really going to tell
us whether or not they can hold on to
that number one seed especially because
for the for the ravens
look they still have to play the browns
and the steelers to end the season and
they got the rams and the 49ers coming
up the browns and the steelers are three
games behind the ravens but i guarantee
you both of those teams are going to
give the ravens everything they can
handle because they're going to want to
try to screw things up for the ravens
they don't want them to be the number
one seed even if cleveland's
mathematically eliminated even if the
steelers are done come the final week of
the season they're going to come after
the ravens hard and the browns have
already beaten them once so even though
they're 8-2 and they've won six games in
a row we can't forget things that
happened early on and one of the things
that happened early on is cleveland
somehow went into baltimore and managed
to win the game but it just feels like
the ravens are operating on a higher
plane right now and i feel like they're
going to catch the patriots at some
point down the stretch you mentioned
three through six and there is a lot of
flux there and look i i think that we
can't process the idea that the raiders
could actually win the division but they
can win the division chris sure of
course they can and they can do exactly
what you've seen we've seen the
indianapolis colts do to the kansas city
chiefs at home which is they can
bludgeon them with the run game control
the clock a little bit like we saw the
chargers in the first half last night
and you know keep mahomes and company on
the side i mean uh one of the most
efficient offenses in the sport right
now is the oakland raiders between their
run game and derek carr being extremely
accurate in that short to intermediate
pass game so that's dangerous i don't
look in any of the teams three four five
or six chiefs colts texans or bills as
being really complete well-rounded teams
yet
and of course the raiders nipping at
their heels the you know with with the
the steelers still alive in this
conversation i mean there's just a lot
of football to be played still and um
i don't i just wonder who was going to
be the team like to you to you if you
had to pick the one team there right out
of all those teams we just mentioned to
where you say okay it's the patriots and
the ravens we know that
who do you think at the end of the day
is going to be that third team that we
go and them they might be able to upset
one of those two teams in a divisional
round who is it going to be because
right now i don't know
yeah and i'm looking not just at the
other teams that are currently in the
playoff window but beyond that is there
a team that could roll into baltimore or
new england and win in the divisional
round and i'm just not sure that there
is right right now in the afc the cars
are like the only team i look at a
little just because of that offensive
line and if they can get t.y hilton and
devin funches back healthy to where
their offense might be able to dictate
games and their defense is solid it's
not like one of the best in football but
it's in the top half of the league
they're the one team i look at and of
course with frank reich's game planning
as we talk about a lot
they're the one team i look at that
might be the the not in the room for the
ravens or the patriots if that time came
yeah i don't disagree with that at all
and i'm looking now at the teams after
the six that are in playoff position is
there a team there i mean we say the
steelers but my god they look so bad
last thursday night against the browns
you know i go back to what we discussed
on thursday hey the steelers they've
lost to the patriots and the ravens the
49ers and you know they've lost some
great teams
and then they just get completely shut
down by the browns and it's a different
feeling about the steelers do you
believe that they can find their way
through the end of the season schedule
and and and be a team that would be
difficult to beat when january rolls
around and no i don't believe it because
i just don't think their defense can
dominate every week and cause turnovers
and strip sack fumbles and pick sixes
and all that at some point the offense
has to do something and what got lost in
the melee last week with miles garrett
and everything was an absolutely pitiful
game by mason rudolph and it does you
know you feel bad saying it because he
got whacked over the head with a helmet
and that's certainly i feel bad for him
there i mean that was some bs we know
that but well yeah but the good news is
getting whacked over the head with the
helmet made us all forget that he threw
four interceptions he played horrible he
played horrible like to the point where
you know i would have thinking about
putting hodges in and i'm not so sure
hodges wouldn't be the best answer for
the start this week he's a better
thrower than mason rudolph he gives them
a chance in the passing game hey it's
always concerning when a team has to
change their offense to a bunch of three
and four yard throws to fit the
quarterback i mean that kind of tells
you something now they drafted them and
they're stubborn and they're going to
try to make it work because they're
trying to sell themselves on that he
could be the future or for ben
rossberger yeah well i seriously
question that you know they haven't been
winning some of those games through
their winning stretch because of mason
rudolph i can tell you that it's because
of that front seven and minka
fitzpatrick and uh yeah that that's my
concern with the steelers i just don't
know if it's realistic to win the way
they've won during that stretch
yeah and you know
all of these events are unfolding within
the context of the nfl dusting off the
colin kaepernick question but chris
isn't it fair to ask when you look at
the steelers current depth
100 whether or not kaepernick would and
why wouldn't you want that if you're
trying to catch the ravens if you're
trying to compete with the ravens you
could try to to out raven the ravens
with a quarterback who was doing the
things lamar jackson is doing now six
and seven years ago oh yeah and the
steelers are kind of built to kind of
play that we saw that they put in
running backs at quarterback with jalen
samuels that's how they did to start off
when ben roethlisberger was hurt but you
know the spectacle
around colin kaepernick is just not
going to help him at this point to get
on a team and i don't think a team like
the steelers is going to want to deal
with it so that's the big issue there i
just you know more than anything it's
going to be like man you know do we
really want to deal with the questions
and the fanfare and the backlash on a
day-to-day basis and that's the
disheartening thing at least from the
colin kaepernick standpoint from last
weekend is you know he didn't defuse any
of that uh they'll all but you know what
but here's the thing mike thomas could
get to the podium and he could say hey
folks we're trying to win football games
sure and right now we don't have our
franchise quarterback in ben
roethlisberger and we're we're not good
enough offensively to win football games
and here's a guy that we think can help
us win and we're going to see we're
going to bring him in for a tryout and
if it looks good we're going to put him
on the team and when he's ready to go if
he's the best option we have he's going
to go because we're trying to win enough
games to get to the playoffs and i'm not
going to make any apologies for that
blah blah blah that's what he would say
they signed mike vick at one point for
crying out loud i'd like to think that
any team that ever signed mike vick
after he served two years in prison
for
dog fighting and was never prosecuted in
virginia as he should have been for
killing dogs deemed unfit to die while
fighting other dogs
if you can embrace him
and don't get me started i've already
started well it's all right i understand
they're both bad and i get what you mean
you're right no they're not both bad one
is horrible and the other one did
nothing wrong yeah well yeah you're
right but it's a very divisive very
divisive subject that's the problem
right there and that you know so you're
right i get it i just don't see it
happening i do agree with you mike
tomlin is the type of guy that can
handle colin kaepernick in that
situation he's the champion of press
conferences and and communicating to
players and all that but i just don't
see it happening at this point as far as
the nfl is concerned for colin
kaepernick and last week was a bad look
for both sides but it doesn't help
kaepernick one other thing too can we
just bring up what i don't mean to
change the subject but i just find this
fascinating about the afc playoff
picture too like the bills this is where
i just think like everybody is still
alive in the afc one through ten i mean
even the four and six browns are there
the bill's got the broncos the cowboys
the ravens the steelers and the patriots
all on the horizon they could lose every
one of those and then when you look at
teams like the texans where they could
lose to the patriots and the titans and
the cults again as well you start to go
man this might maybe this is a year an
eight and eight team gets in in the afc
i mean it's starting to shape up where
that could be a real possibility and
that's the crazy thing to me more than
anything um
sorry i just wanted to get that out of
my mouth sorry no i mean here's the
thing it's patriots ravens and it's wide
open wide open for the other four spots
wide open yes it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports